[Music]
on this monday night we're learning
more politicians left the country over
the holidays
the fallout for public figures who took
trips abroad
while canadians were told to stay home
it just scares me how out of touch with
the people that they are
hospitalizations rising it's a dangerous
trend bracing for a post-holiday spike
in infections in covid 19 hot spots
plus the great british lockdown i'm
afraid
you must once again stay at home another
round of strict orders in the uk
as cases soar out of control and
dropping the puck on another pandemic
hockey season
canada's nhl teams get ready to face off
in a new division
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
after a tough winter break for so many
canadians the backlash is building
against politicians
who flouted public health advice to
avoid travel
across the country the list of
provincial and federal politicians
who left canada over the holidays is
growing in alberta tonight there is
major fallout
premier jason kenney says united
conservative mla tracy allard has
resigned from cabinet
she went on a family vacation to hawaii
the premier's chief of staff who
traveled to the uk has also resigned
and five other mlas have been demoted
at first jason kenney said he had no
plans to sanction
any members of his government for
traveling as heather york's west reports
in tonight's top story
he underestimated the public outrage
for nine-year-old braden a hawaii
vacation would have been a trip
of a lifetime brayden loves the ocean
has always
loved the ocean even before he was
crawling he would lay on the sand and
just roll
and laugh around braden has a rare
genetic disease and
isn't expected to live to see his teens
the make-a-wish foundation was going to
make hawaii a reality
until kovit 19 took that wish away
so when his mom first heard about the
alberta politicians floating coveted
travel restrictions
to jedov to mexico and hawaii she was
hurt
it was a kick in the teeth i couldn't
believe it to know that they're
basically
thumbing their noses and maintaining
their own family traditions to go to
hawaii was just
over the top i spent christmas alone
at first alberta's premier blamed
himself for members of his own
government
taking trips here i take responsibility
for not
having clearly set out or communicated a
policy
against international travel for senior
decision makers in government
but the outrage grew forcing the premier
to do and about face
on social media jason kenny revealed
that six united conservative party mlas
were demoted
and as chief of staff has resigned by
traveling abroad over the holidays kenny
said
these individuals demonstrated extremely
poor judgment
it's a bit too little too late we often
see
situations where you don't make the
right decision at the right time
you wait then you make it but it's too
little and it doesn't
stop the the masses there are concerns
the actions of government officials
have now set a dangerous precedent when
every day albertans are seeing
that ministers are traveling
their first response may be well okay
well why don't i just have a few people
over to my house or
do i really have to wear this mask do i
really have to stay at home if i have a
small tickle in my throat
the premier will have to test public
confidence in his authority very soon
the province is set to review its
current round of covert restrictions
next week heather urex west global news
calgary
it's not just provincial politicians
who've traveled outside canada during
the pandemic
the federal liberals say two of their
mps went to the u.s
kamal kara for memorial service and
samir zuberi to see a sick relative
new democrat nikki ashton was stripped
of her critic roles
after she revealed she went to greece to
visit her sick grandmother
and conservative mp ron leipert says
he's been to palm desert california
twice since march for what he called
essential house maintenance issues
david aiken has been tracking the
fallout from these travels david
now we're learning another conservative
mp and senator were out of the country
how's the party handling that that's
right and the senator in this case
is don plett and senator plett is the
conservative leader in the senate
he went to mexico on december 28th then
thought better of it
turned around and came back on the 31st
he's now quarantined
at quarantining at his home in south of
winnipeg
but we also learned that a conservative
mp from ontario david sweet
also traveled to the u.s and like his
caucus mate ron leipert
swede left to attend to a property issue
but then he stayed on to holiday and he
did that
without notifying his party and so as a
result sweet
like the two liberal mps and the ndp mp
has lost some of his parliamentary
duties in swede's case
he has resigned as chair of the house of
commons ethics committee
now we're learning about these because
the leader's offices
from all parties here in ottawa have in
the last few days
put the word out that any mp who left
the country
should step forward and step forward now
now
all the parties liberals conservatives
to democrats and the black quebecois
now say that they are confident that it
is just this group of five mps
that left canada in december senators
they're a bit of another matter because
party leaders
have less control over them and for the
record both prime minister justin
trudeau
and opposition leader aaron o'toole
spent the holidays with their families
at their official residences right here
in the national capital
and the pmo says no cabinet minister has
left the country since
march with the exception of the foreign
affairs minister who did leave canada
but only on official government business
now in the meantime dozens of mps
are proactively disclosing that they did
not travel in fact
some tell me they have been responding
to calls from constituents
wanting to know what they did for
christmas and where they were
now the second thing robin we may have a
federal election this year
and any candidate that wants to run
always goes to a vetting process
that's run by party headquarters well
this year candidates can expect more
than just a financial or a criminal
background check
candidates are going to be asked when
did you last leave the country
and why robin david how does this put
politicians under more public scrutiny
than ever before
the concern now is that trust in
politicians federal or provincial
has been eroded by the actions of those
that traveled for
what are clearly non-essential purposes
i mean to grab some sun in las vegas or
hawaii or the caribbean and their travel
puts
any legitimate international travel of
other politicians
in a bad light and that in turn is going
to make it more difficult
when the prime minister or premiers have
to ask canadians
for more sacrifices to fight this
pandemic
robin david aiken in ottawa thanks david
a member of quebec's liberal party has
been punished for spending his christmas
vacation
in the caribbean pierre akang has been
stripped of his shadow cabinet positions
in quebec's national assembly
his party ordered him to return home
last week after it emerged he was on
holidays in barbados
arkham says he regrets his decision to
travel and will remain in quarantine
for 14 days in saskatchewan mla joe
hargrave has resigned from cabinet
he revealed last week that he traveled
to palm springs california on december
22nd
he says he went to finalize the sale of
a personal property
residents at montreal's maimonides
geriatrics center will have to wait a
little longer for the second dose of the
pfizer biontech vaccine
residents at the facility were among the
first in quebec to get their first shots
three weeks ago they've now been told
the second round
is delayed the province has instead
decided to inoculate as many people as
possible
with a first dose pfizer and partner
biontech are warning they have no
evidence their vaccine will continue to
protect against the virus
if the booster shot isn't administered
within 21 days
and today in ontario a personal support
worker became the first in the province
to get that second shot and be
fully vaccinated against kovan 19. four
of her colleagues were also
inoculated ontario recorded a staggering
3270
infections today in toronto alone 917
cases were reported
and today new lockdown measures took
effect aimed at curbing the spread of
the virus
in workplaces among the changes toronto
public health will begin sharing
specific information
on workplace outbreaks without
compromising privacy
including at grocery stores and offices
businesses must also
immediately notify public health about
two or more positive cases
and employers must minimize cases where
more than one person travels in a car
for work related reasons ontario and
quebec
are the two provinces driving canada's
rise in infections
this country has now surpassed 600 000
cases of covet 19.
and with hospitalization surging health
officials are warning
anyone suffering from covet fatigue to
take the pandemic seriously
here's eric sorenson the coldest time of
year is just beginning but covet 19 has
a big head start on the peak season for
virus transmissions
over the holidays there was a surge in
travel and family gatherings
and hospitals are seeing a worrying
increase in covid admissions
nationally hospitalizations have risen
to just over four thousand
higher than at any time since the
pandemic began
some hospitals are running out of
capacity to care for those who need it
most
it's a dangerous trend if we keep seeing
hospitalization rise it's a dangerous
trend if we keep seeing
intensive care occupancy rise and uh
that's why we
uh really called so strongly for the
the lockdown before christmas but many
canadians did not lock down before
christmas
the leading indicators for
hospitalizations are the case numbers
confirmed cases far exceed what was
counted last spring
now averaging over six thousand per day
but it's not progressing evenly across
the country
in bc manitoba and the maritimes cases
peaked primarily in late november then
dropped off
alberta saskatchewan and newfoundland
and labrador saw numbers peak in early
and mid-december
the most troubling numbers are in
ontario and quebec where cases
surged last month and have continued to
rise
it's not clear when it will peak in the
two biggest provinces
many canadians took precautions but the
holiday surge isn't fully accounted for
yet
the numbers have gone up fairly
aggressively over the holiday season and
people
i would think have not maintained total
vigilance in that regard
toronto alone reported more than 900 new
cases
the new cases we are seeing today are
likely the result of transmission
before christmas even when we all stay
home as much as possible it takes weeks
to see the results of our collective
sacrifice ontario has reported three new
cases of the highly contagious uk
variant
one more reason to fear a coming surge
the message
stop traveling i cannot emphasize how
important this is
covet 19 does not know borders now that
the holidays have passed
health officials hope canadians will
take even more seriously
the need right now to avoid
non-essential travel
and non-essential contacts eric sorensen
global news
toronto by the time most canadians
settled back into their work day today
canada's top
ceos had already made what the average
person makes
all year in 2019 the average total
compensation for the 100 highest-paid
chief executives in canada
was 10.8 million dollars the average
annual salary for a canadian worker that
year
just over 53 000 early estimates for
2020 a year when most struggled
financially
show that roughly half of canada's top
paid ceos will likely keep
or even increase their compensation
levels more than a third of the ceos on
the list work for companies
that received the emergency wage subsidy
the good news and the bad news in
britain coming up a new vaccine rolls
out as the country goes
into another lockdown plus wikileaks
founder avoids extradition
for now
faced with a surge in covid19 cases
british prime minister boris johnson has
announced another lockdown in england
similar to the one in march people can
only leave home for essential reasons
and all schools will be closed
regimen shannon reports on the dire
situation
a bright start to the day in the uk the
cheaper and easy to store oxford
astrazeneca vaccine
in use for the first time anywhere
but the reality of the pandemic here
remains
i do want to stress for everybody the
the the efforts that we're making
as a government to try to keep primary
schools open
prime minister boris johnson is battling
a crisis and
the more contagious uk virus variant
that experts say
is out of control the virus is just
going to get a tighter
and tighter grip on communities right
across the country
and vaccination is not going to come
quick enough to help us
the country's chief medical officers
demanded immediate action
i am more concerned about the situation
we face now
than i have been at any time since march
last year
scotland's first minister imposed a
legally enforceable stay-at-home order
for january coming on a day when one of
her own mps was arrested for using
public transit
while she was knowingly infected with
covet 19.
by evening the prime minister issued
similar orders for people in england
we must therefore go into a national
lockdown already rolling back on his
morning optimism when it comes to
education
primary schools secondary schools and
colleges across
england must move to remote permit
provision
from tomorrow suddenly it feels like
march 2020 again
johnson hinted that this lockdown is
expected to last
well into february or even march 2021
pending a very rapid vaccine rollout i
know
how frustrated you are and i know that
you've had
more than enough of government guidance
about defeating this virus
as for the rest of the uk wales had
already issued a stay-at-home order
since christmas
northern ireland is now looking to do
something similar
redmond shannon global news london
still ahead the president's new efforts
to defy democracy
in the u.s voters are getting ready to
head back to the polls in georgia for
two key runoff races that will determine
who controls the senate but president
donald trump is more fixated on his own
loss in that state as a last-ditch
attempt
to overturn the election veers into
dangerous new territory
our washington bureau chief jackson
proskow reports
this is all easily provably
false yet the president persists
officials in georgia are at wit's end
once again forced to defend the
integrity of the election
after repeated baseless attacks by the
president and his allies
they're making wild claims that again
undermine
people's faith in the system on saturday
the secretary of state got an earful
during a phone call from an angry
president trump who pressured him to
overturn
joe biden's victory in the state i just
want to find
11 780
votes which is one more that we have
because we won the state and flipping
the state
is a great testament to our country the
call is remarkable not just for its
seeming abuse of power or disregard for
democracy
but because it shows the president's
genuine belief in debunked internet
conspiracy theories about voter fraud
i won this election by hundreds of
thousands of votes there's no way i lost
georgia there's no way
the data that he has is just plain wrong
we've you know
he had hundreds and hundreds of people
he said that were dead they voted
we found two to date none of the voter
fraud claims have held up
we've seen in the last two months
unprecedented allegations of voter fraud
that hasn't stopped trump's republican
enablers from
pushing the theories anyway on wednesday
at least a dozen republican senators and
more than 140 members of the house
will use that as a pretext to object to
president-elect joe biden's win
during the count of the electoral
college votes i promise you come this
wednesday
we'll have our day in congress we'll
hear the objections
we'll hear the evidence even trump
loyalists have warned it's a risky
strategy that could divide the party and
undermine democracy election officials
in georgia have already warned all those
false claims of voter fraud
risked turning off republican voters
ahead of tuesday's senate runoff
elections in the state
the pressure campaign may also be
legally risky for trump
democrats have sent a criminal referral
to the fbi
while back in georgia state officials
have not ruled out a criminal probe
into whether trump broke the law by
demanding an election result that simply
doesn't exist
robin jackson prescott washington thanks
jackson
a big victory today for wikileaks
founder julian assange
a judge in the uk has ruled he will not
be extradited to the u.s
[Music]
[Applause]
cheers erupted outside the court today
when the ruling came down
assange has been held in a british
prison for more than 18 months before
that he spent seven years in asylum at
ecuador's embassy in london
american prosecutors indicted him on 17
espionage charges
and one charge of computer misuse they
stemmed from publications of leaked
military and diplomatic documents a
decade ago
today the judge said assange would be a
suicide risk if held under harsh u.s
prison conditions we are pleased that
the court
has recognized the seriousness and
inhumanity
of what he has endured and what he faces
but let's not forget the indictment in
the u
s has not been dropped
assange's lawyers say if convicted he
stands to face 175 years in an american
jail
the u.s government says it will appeal
today's decision
up next canada's hockey teams gear up
for another pandemic season
with only each other
all right if you're a hockey fan don't
despair the season is just over a week
away
there may not be as many games as normal
but is anything normal these days
as mike armstrong explains the creation
of a new division will involve a lot of
action
between canadian teams
it's not lost on the players what their
return to the ice
means for sports fans living in a
pandemic the nhl is a welcome
distraction
the players feel the same way you know i
know for me watching
nfl games and having things like that to
look forward to
sometimes takes you out of the the
reality of the world we're living
there won't be much regular about this
regular season
first of all it comes without a
preseason the first game
the teams will play we don't have time
to waste we'll count to the standings
every day every drill is important it's
designed for something and our focus has
to be there right from
the start of today right till of game
one now there won't be a bubble this
season teams will be playing home games
at home but the nhl has divided the
league into four
new divisions and the canadian teams
will only play each other
that means the montreal canadiens for
example will play the vancouver canucks
more times this season than they have in
the last
five combined it's going to be fun it's
going to be it's going to be interesting
for everybody
obviously playing the same teams over
and over it's going to
it's going to get heated at some points
where teams usually have the chance to
cool down after a tough game
this year they're likely to go right
back at it to cut down on travel
and the possibility of spreading the
virus between teams
the league's borrowed from baseball
they're going to be playing multiple
games against the same team
at one point montreal plays ottawa four
straight despite that the new
configuration does mean
extra strain for the canadian teams
we're in the division that travels the
most
of all the divisions in this league this
year we're going from one end of the
country
to the other the nfl wrapped up its
regular season sunday
there were hiccups but they did get
through without any cancellations
that bodes well for the nhl every sport
is taking best practices from the other
sports
and it's good to see that the
commissioners are all talking to each
other sharing that intel
now ratings were weak for last year's
nhl playoffs playoff hockey in august
was perhaps not a natural sell
the hope is if this season wraps up as
scheduled next season could start at the
normal time of the year the fall
possibly post pandemic hopefully
mike armstrong global news montreal
and that is global national for this
monday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is the yukon river
in whitehorse
we love seeing your part of the country
so email your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you